all right it is a very busy day today
but I do have hatred mail for you hatred
mail of course a quick reminder a
professional voice-over artist
interprets the various hate mails that I
get quick reminder because we cling to
our guns and our God but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to
assault our wife Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom so something
in this week's hatred mail doesn't sound
quite right something about it strikes
me as maybe an insincere detail that the
hatred is providing to us let's take a
listen hey David why don't you use some
of that Jew insider capital with Google
and stop their algorithm from screwing
your channel over clearly David is
controlled opposition David I'm a
beautiful woman mostly black in the past
I dated every race but absolutely no
Jews or do you meant attracted hmm your
videos are read it'll is well listen
thank you for clarifying that you don't
date Jews but why do I have a feeling
that the hatred isn't really the
beautiful black women that claim to be I
don't know I I have a little bit of
trouble believing that fight hate friut
ISM with the coupon code hey tree at 40
H 80 are IOT for 0 that's a coupon code
which will save you 40% off of any
membership at join pakman.com but it
makes the hatreds cry because their
futile attempts to take down the show
clearly are failing a hatred for T for
any membership